Film Courage: Can you explain the 8-sequence
template?
Paul Joseph Gulino, Associate Professor at
Chapman University Dodge College of Film and
Media Arts: Sure.
This originates in two ways, two places.
It originates in Hollywood history by the
ancient of the one reel film (35 millimeter
film) that became standardized by the first
decade of the 20th century.
The first movies by that time (by 1910) they
are single reel experiences that are 10 minutes
long.
And for various reasons in the 1910 era Hollywood
split in two directions from the single reel
film to what we call full length features
(multi reel films - hour and a half to two
hours) and in the other direction to the serial
which is a reel or two installment series.
The reason you have the origin of sequences
is that in the US the distribution system
was so rigorously one reel a week or two reels
a week that when the start to change that
when the started to generate full-length feature
films they were still distributed a couple
of reels a week.
So if you look at manuals of the time (screenwriting
manuals) there were about 60 titles that came
in the 1910’s on how to write a photoplay
because the market was wide open and people
wanted to write these things.
You’ll get instructions about making sure
each reel has a climax to it so that the audience
will be interested in seeing the next reel
and then they will see the next one after
that so it was almost like a limited series
(a feature film).
By the late 1910’s you are seeing the distribution
system is changing and you are seeing in theaters
what we would normal experience as a full-length
feature.
But the idea of writing by the reel survived
into the 20’s and 30’s and you can see
it the way that the continuity scripts are
marked.
They are often marked by sequence letter.
Sequence A, B, C, D. And that is where what
we call sequences (the nomenclature) comes
from.
What Frank Daniel discovered in teaching in
the eighties he discussed the three-act structure
in terms of developing it and paying it off
but he found that the students struggled with
the middle part of the script because it’s
intimidating.
How do you fill up 60 pages in the middle?
And usually 30 pages to set it up, 60 pages
in the middle, and 30 pages in the third act.
So he revived this idea of sequences.
He said well don’t think of it as one act
of 60 pages.
Think of it as four 15-minute scripts that
each one builds on the last so thus the sequence
approach is born.
You’re not going to tackle the whole 120
pages.
Just figure out the first 15 minutes (the
first one) and then the next 15 minutes.
That’s going to lead to some kind of major
problem for our character.
So then they are going to try to explore that
for the next 15 minutes.
And the effect is actually very liberating
because you end up not worrying about how
you are going to fill up these pages but about
how you are going to trim down because now
you have all of this material.
But it also helps you explore a premise really
fully.
You have a character, let’s just take a
classic dramatic instructions, a character
wants something and there are obstacles okay?
At the end of the first act we know what they
want and we know what the obstacles are going
to be.
What is the character going to do?
The character doesn’t know what the movie
is about.
The character just thinks “This is easy,
I can solve this.”
So they try something and this is in your
conceptualization of the story.
The character tries the easiest thing they
can try.
And then the filmmaker, the screenwriter comes
up with an obstacle of why that doesn’t
work and that’s maybe 10-15 minutes.
Alright now they’ve got to try something
else.
What’s that going to be?
And you can develop it and each sequence has
its own integrity ideally that what the paradigm
is that each sequence is going to have three
acts also.
It’s going to have some kind of set-up.
You don’t have to have as much set-up because
you know the characters but you are going
to have to introduce new circumstances.
They are going to try to get something and
then it’s going to end with some kind of
resolution usually negative because if it’s
positive then the movie is over.
But it leads to the next sequence and then
the next one.
So you wind up with actually kind of a nested
structure because the dramatic scenes have
the same three acts.
That’s why we tend to like three acts.
It depends on how you define it.
But if you understand it as working with tension
were tension is just putting something in
the audiences mind (hope and fear).
Your character wants something, are they going
to get it or not?
That’s what I’m wondering about.
And if I care about the character then I’m
going to stay tuned because I’m going to
want to see the answer to that.
So you don’t need more than three acts for
that, you just need to set that up and then
you need to develop it and then you get the
answer.
So each act set up the whole thing.
Then each sequence has its own…okay the
character wants something and then there are
problems.
And then each scene has something the character
wants something and then there are obstacles.
So it’s like this iterative structure that
keeps the audience involved because we’re
constantly wondering about how that’s going
to come out for the character.
And one thing that we cover in the book The
Science of Screenwriting: The Neuroscience
Behind Storytelling Strategies is this process
of connection to a main character and what
the theories are about why we have that.
It’s certainly important if you come into
a park and you come up on a tennis game and
two people are really battling each other
it may be interesting but it’s not going
to be dramatic to you because you don’t
know them.
But if you do know one of them, if you love
one them and you know that they just mortgaged
your house and put everything on this game
and then you know the other person is a hustler
then every…Oh my gosh!
You’ve got something that is transformational.
But you’ve got to make that connection emotionally.
To get back about the sequence structure you
have many versions of the three acts in the
sequences and then in the scenes.
And that is the suspense (the tension) that
keeps us interested.
We also have a chapter on contrast in the
film.
And that plays also into this approach which
is in order to maintain audience attention
the stimulus has to be changed frequently
otherwise you zone out, you lose connection,
you will think about other things and you
need reset the audiences brain periodically.
And filmmakers do it you can see evidence
of it in changing light and dark, loud and
soft, fast and slow.
But you also see it in tension and release.
Tension maintained for too long gets tedious.
But if you release it and give it a chance
to reset then you can go on to build it up
again and again and again until you reach
the culmination of the picture and then finally
you try to release it entirely and get people
to say “Yes, I want to see that movie again.
I’m going to tell all my friends I’m going
to see it.”
Film Courage: Is it based on a time limit?
Is there an actual science down to the minute
of what we can handle in terms of when our
mind wanders?
Professor Gulino: My understanding is (and
this is something that Dr. Connie Shears might
be able to confirm) but our attention can
maybe last about 3 to 5 minutes.
And then we need to reset it somehow.
And dramatic scenes tend to be about 3 minutes,
usually about three pages.
And before you need to have some new character
enter, you cut away, you have a new development,
something to scramble it up.
The basic premise of this book, the inspiration
of doing the The Science of Screenwriting:
The Neuroscience Behind Storytelling Strategies
was if you see patterns in movies and you
see patterns in the advice about movies is
there a deeper reason for it?
Is there a physiological basis for it.
There is a New Yorker [Magazine] cartoon that
kind of illustrates that idea.
There’s a movie theater and it’s filled
with cats.
All of the cats are the whole audience.
And on screen is a shoe with a shoelace that
is loose.
Okay, a cat is going to find that completely
enthralling, a human being maybe not so much.
But what we do find enthralling, you’re
going to see the patterns.
We are going to look for certain things and
be satisfied by certain things.
The physiology kind of determines what we’re
seeing on screen.
I kind of see the book (as I mentioned) as
an argument settler.
What’s fashionable.
What advice is essential, what isn’t.
What do we need to know?
What do we not need to know?
Go back to the scientific basis for things
and see is there something there that dictates
it or is it just an option?
That’s part of the inspiration for it.